what's your favorite sports anime what'd
you say not counting ping-pong
because that's like that's a human drama
that's a lifetime that was like a good
good Sports Anime so far and Beyond what
you're what you see in your typical
Sports Anime yeah that I don't know I
think if I watch crocodone because I
watched all of croconawasket if I watch
that now I don't think I could sit
through it I think I sat through it at a
time where that was appealing to me yes
and I have to recognize that my anime
tastes have changed and Sports Anime
definitely appeals to that kind of uh
Teenage part of my brain that loves over
hyped and superpowers in real life yeah
like I think
I think as a kid you really like put
yourself in those situations where
you're like hey I wish I could be like
this in sport like I wish I could be the
goat like I wish
and I can I can kind of be like whoa
that's [__] sick so yeah to answer
what is my favorite sports anime it's
hard to say because like I really
enjoyed watching crocono basket but I
don't think I can sit through it now I
weirdly enough I like the omushi pedal
but I didn't finish it because they have
so much [__] episodes yeah I watched
like the first two seasons and I digged
it but again I can't think of any sports
anime I kind of liked a lot I thought
free was okay but it kept trying to be
they kept trying to like just get horny
the question is that a Sports Anime
though uh well yeah that is a Sports
Anime it's a horny anime that disguises
itself as Sports yeah that's true your
life is pretty good yeah it was I
thought it was that was a great story
um I'm horrible Sports Anime is that
like you're in it for the long term like
it's always it's always like uh and I
get it because you have to show the
growing yeah I also okay another thing
about blue log that pissed me off I hate
it when they try and make out that I'll
protect is like the weakest one there
and it's like he's obviously [__] not
like he's like ranked two 299 out of
300. it's like [__] off No One Believes
that it's the my hero formula yeah and
I'm like none of us believe that this
guy's the shittest here straight up like
let's just want them to make a Shonen
where they started off like the
protagonist is the shittest one and he
just Remains the shittest one for them
that or like let's just be honest he's
like the 20th out of 300.
and we watch a guy who's already very
talented just work much harder to become
the goat like right why stop setting
stop doing this like it's obviously he's
not the shittest in real life if you're
the shittish you're gonna still be the
shittiest see this is this is another
reason why I still think slam dunk is
the goat because what they did with
hanamichi the main character is that
like they built it up at the beginning
is like he's never played basketball
before but he has the physical prowess
to become the greatest basketball yeah
and seeing that and he starts off [__]
but he's so confident in himself yeah
and so cocky about himself that when he
does go into a match and pull off a six
slam dunk you're just like [__] yeah
yeah it's yeah I guess my problem is
suspension of disbelief and how often I
have to do it with these shows yeah it's
it like I you know talking to you it
sounds like you in entertainment your
taste of more geared towards something
grounded and something more yeah I mean
you know it's not natural progression
yeah not to say that I wouldn't like
obviously if there's some dumb [__] in
chainsaw man I'm gonna be like oh cool
but it's like okay you know you're
talking shocker you're talking football
right where whatever it is which is
rooted in reality
I would argue that chainsaw man fought
as ridiculous as is feels more grounded
for sure anything in blue look and
that's just because you know I look at
someone like Wayne's the rules of the
world yeah I look at something like
chainsaw man I look at something like
blue look blue lock is you know you know
when you talk to someone and you're like
oh yeah this was like really anime you
know blue lock has everything that gives
you that feeling of just like all all of
these anime
bullshit-esque things that we've just
got all gotten used to for sure yeah and
you think of so many shows like like
blue look that is just like oh this is
just when I think of what a typical
anime is like in terms of all the tropes
and everything that we kind of uh
criticize not criticize but parody anime
to be about it's all in blue lock when I
look at chainsaw man I see uh something
that I see really grounded and well
thought out characters in a [__]
insane world yeah I mean the most
unrealistic thing about chainsaw man is
how how well that man is able to
function drunk all the time that's
literally the most unrealistic part that
like where I have to really suspend my
disbelief sure I don't know man if
you've seen alcoholic she's like some
people just no that guy's straight up
drinking from The Flash non-stop ain't
no way he's fighting that good change my
mind that's where I draw that's right
stay in Wisconsin
tonight's average Irish person
introduce myself
he's so sharp in that show I don't see
that good and that drunk all the time
and that coherent he never stumbles once
it's interesting the Sports Anime right
because like I totally get like the
whole like grounded thing because like
you know that's what makes again like I
hate to sound like a broken record
that's what makes it shows like slam
dunk so great but on but I feel there's
just as much of an equal enjoyment on
the entire opposite side of the spectrum
yeah where like something like Prince of
Tennis right like that thing is so
[__] unrealistic to the point where
it's just entertaining oh yeah like it's
so stupid where it's like from the
beginning you know you're not going to
take this you're the one punch man of
sports yeah yeah like I think the it
feels that Sports Anime haven't changed
in like 20 years
like it feels like they've barely
changed and the formula never changes
and then like you know another thing
that pissed me off in blue lock if
you've watched it they introduce this
one character and I don't know why this
annoyed me so much but I just was like
God this is the dumbest [__] they
introduced this character who is like
amazing at football and uh he he plays
overseas in the European leagues he's
like he's a college student he's like I
refuse to play in Japan they're all
peasants and not good enough at the game
and then he overheards this new blue
lock Pro he's like I'm listening cancel
my flight I'm staying in Japan I'm like
God this is
so [__] dumb and then it asks you to
take it so seriously like 10 seconds
later yeah like which one like which
which which kind of which what level of
disbelief and what which level of
seriousness do you want me to engage
with this yeah I just don't get it like
yeah um dunk is great for me like that
ball Shield I shoot was great but I said
like slam dang's perfect for me and I
should just [__] read it yes just
re-slamed on yeah just re-slamp I don't
know like Sports Anime to me I I really
like just because of how ridiculous it
was with with like it's uh Battle Royale
formats I I feel like you either go one
way or the other yeah you either go this
really grounded take like slam dunk or
you go something ridiculous and just
[__] have fun with it yeah
um like a Sports Anime I watched
recently which kind of went like the
ridiculous route uh is an anime called
birdy wink oh yeah
um and it's a golf anime and I'm like
how the [__] do you make no I I believe
Golf Course how do you how would you how
would you make golf fun to watch yeah
and you and you make it fun to watch but
I adding all of the at like every single
anime [__] power you can think of
like this time reversal so so there's uh
so we start off with
um this so it's it's a golf anime but
the main character she says that she's
not a golfer she doesn't play golf all
she does is hit a ball with a stick
that's why she does right she's a happy
Gilman
and and it's basically so what happens
is you take these like Mario you played
Mario Golf yeah of course you take these
like Mario Golf as Aesthetics and
power-ups and stuff like that and then
you add it into a secret underground
Society where you have life or death
games yes that sounds awesome if you're
gonna go as far that far just add depth
yeah yeah of course make that the
punishment yeah yeah because uh with
Buddy when there's this underground
Society where people have like betting
games on golf matches and it's like life
or death and someone has built like us
there's like this golf Seto Kaiba that
has built this underground facility
where they can like reprogrammed their
Golf Course to whatever like whatever
they want and so the there's golfers
come from all over the world to have
life or death bets on golf matches at
this place right
um and then there's just this whole
subplot about the underground
organization you're watching a golf
anime and then some guy just gets like
kamikazeed in the middle of a [__]
road there's like some guy takes up an
RPG and just blows up this guy on the
road I'm like am I watching a [__]
golf anime or what but like that's what
you need to make that's better fun as
[__] to watch go watch bloody Wing
that's that's actually like a really
underrated uh Sports is there like a
pegasus type character that can see like
the exact place there like he needs to
like [__] like everyone hash everyone
has like some [__] [__] I love
that